les mecs qui sont bilingues enfin ceux
qui parle bien anglais en général cela
réponde pas trop haut ce qui est bien
c'est que c'est pas la peine de leur
demander s'ils parlent qu'anglais
ce mec là et qu'ils aiment bien le
rappeler toutes les 30 secondes
ouais j'ai écouté ce que justement du
jazz manouche et de la minimale à un
mailing va
qu'est-ce que tu confonds les deux
langues si vous êtes y compris le thème
de ce bon monsieur
ah oui non ce sens américain mais j'en
ai marre de rêver en anglais ça me
saoule temps sagnières non mais c'est
vrai - avec mes origines je pourrai
jamais me la péter comme ça ce sera
toujours nul j'en ai marre de rêver en
ch'ti oui non parce que je suis bilingue
je suis bilingue chtioui je vécus dans
le nord bon on va pas épiloguer
maintenant on peut pas se répéter quand
on parle ch'tis à l'étoile tout le monde
le calme et j'ai l'impression que les
bilingues ils ont une sorte de besoin de
te [ __ ] la honte et les amis retraite
dans des situations de manière à te
rappeler que t'es une merde à côté de
paul lingl en études que coût facturé
milieu de sa propre ce matelas green à
montbenon je parle pas anglais
bon je suis désolé j'ai pas compris je
parle pas pas bien anglais comme toi tu
parle pas anglais
cj non tu parles quelle langue à tel
point que parfois je fais semblant de
comprendre juste pour la faire plaisir
quoi je suis en train de lire le texte
d'un auteur américain complètement chez
perds tu vas adorer line is a way
gauthier vas-y alors has been been
ce camping
c'est génial le pire c'est pendant les
concerts parce que tu as des milliers de
biens qui se cache dans l'obscurité
tu les vois pas forcément mais c'est
qu'ils sont là alors quand je chantais
entre deux chansons fait une petite
phrase pour le public
tu as la moitié de la salle qui est
comme ça et puis tu allais bilingue
énorme génie un style sommes bien amusés
high speed english bilingue mais
attention le chanteur il veut dire
n'importe quoi tu as toujours un bilan
qui se marrent pour montrer qu'il
accomplit excellent en malaisie il a dit
quoi là il a dit one to one two si ce
test moi tous ces gens qui se la pète
mais m
l'idée enfin bon moi je m'en fous voilà
c'est pas grave j'ai un niveau d'anglais
normal moyens ok j'avoue niveau 6e monte
m'en fous parce que le français c'est
déjà une belle langue jeu ça me suffit
j'aime bien en fait quand les gens me
parlent français parce que je me sens
baigner dans toute une histoire jamais
eu marguerite duras victor hugo le
français c'est une langue vivante qui
évolue chaque jour langue magique qui
belle pleine de fantaisie et de couleurs
rien qu'à voir dans mon quartier les
mecs qui parlent
jo jo doit en bio pour moi ouais donc un
message pour tous les gens qui sont
bilingues
c'est tout là arrêtez arrêtez de faire
les malins parce que c'est pas mal hein
c'est pas malin de se [ __ ] de la
gueule des gens nous on est nul on ne
parle pas comme vous anglais c'est pas
grave
sinon j'ai vu que vous étiez de plus en
plus nombreux sur la page facebook
norman fait des vidéos et ça ça me fait
un gros plaisir sain c'est un loup
plaisir love